Okay.
I want to just finish off cause la trying
to do the collaboration and one week
is not easy. I want to talk a little
bit more about, uh, Vichy and the juice.
And then I mentioned something about
[inaudible] haul the late president of
France and the whole question of,
of forgetting and then remembering
and then I'll, I'll, uh,
leap into a I to resistance.
Um,
just at the beginning, I mean,
just to put the perspective of,
of how the French Vichy forces
or government's treatment
of the Jews compares to
other, to other countries. Um,
that, yeah, in, uh,
November of 1942 that's a crucial period
because is that point that the Germans
occupied the, the so called
free zone or, or Vichy zone.
And at that point Vichy
authorities hand over the Jews, uh,
who had been imprisoned,
I in the Vichy zone,
a to the Nazis and they had mark
their ration cards. You know,
you had to ration cards,
you had to have cards to get a little
bit of butter and all this kind of stuff.
They mark them Zarif. Uh, or as
we've settled on the cock, uh,
which meant Jew, which made
it easier, uh, for, uh,
the German or the French police,
um, uh, tourist them. And, and, uh,
so they, they, they, not only
did they, uh, well, I had, well,
they had to sort of turn over of
what was left of their authority. Uh,
but they, they did, did,
um, uh, they did, uh, uh,
more than the, uh, than they needed to do.
And things were so bad for the Jews at
the hand of the Vichy police that, that,
uh,
when thousands of foreign Jews I had
gone into niece had somehow gotten in,
in, in, uh, gotten into
Nice, uh, which, um,
that which Mussolini's fascist
troops, uh, had occupied,
um, that the, you know, they,
they essentially, uh, uh,
uh, you know, arrested them
or made it easier for the, uh,
for the people there to be identified
and to be in, to be taken by. Um, uh,
by the fascist a and an October,
1942,
when the u s government proposed to take
a thousand Jewish kids whose parents
had been deported without them a PR Laval,
um,
who would get his after the war. And
her neighbor who's gay, who is the, uh,
police had a, who was when it
was, uh, uh, uh, murdered, uh,
before his trial by a guy
seeking publicity for his book.
They replied that only certified
orphans could be given exit visas.
And that's because you couldn't prove
that the parents had already died in the
death camps.
They would not allow the Jewish
children to be deported or to deport it,
to be exiled, to be refugees, uh,
in the United States. So, and,
and Lavalin buscape, both of whom were
frenetic antisemites knew this very well.
So essentially they just
condemn them to, to, um, uh,
to eye eye to their fate and, and
the children couldn't lose. I mean,
you couldn't leave.
And I'm more than five weeks following
the allied invasion of Normandy, which is,
you know, what's on the 6th of June
of 1944. The Vichy police were,
we're still arresting Jews. And right
up until the last, until the last days,
uh, and so many of the cases to the
media, people in the police, uh,
who were gunned down at the end,
at the end of the war, during,
during liberation had been,
you know,
these were people who had gone out of
their way simply to keep on arresting Jews
and, and, and killing Jews. Uh,
when it was clear that the allies
were going to come in and, and, and,
and chase the, uh, the Germans out, uh,
in the eight months of 1944 before
the liberation, almost 15,000 Jews,
uh, were, uh, deported and deported
means, uh, to the death camps.
Um, so, um, anyway,
three quarters of all the Jews who were
arrested in France during the entire
period were arrested, uh,
by, uh, the French, uh,
the French police, a German
director, I mean French director,
our director, I were, or where the
heads of the academy, that is, you know,
Francis divided into academy.
Uh,
that is the whole structure of education
from the universities down to two,
the Matranel to, to, uh,
uh, kindergarten's, uh,
the rector's a domestic Jews from their
post. And you met one of them, uh,
Mark Block of my am I
said lost a job twice.
He lost it in straws and
then in [inaudible]. Yay. Um,
and in my say that the order of doctors
purge juice from the right to practice
and complained that there was still
Jews in medical school. Now and again,
they didn't have to do this. The, the, you
know, the Germans weren't saying, yeah,
you know, they had other
things, uh, you know,
security and things that they were
worried about security in quotes. Uh,
but it was just done, uh,
because they wanted to do it. Uh,
and this the same thing in the
legal profession, uh, where, uh,
lots of magistrates, a as in
the case of, of, uh, of, of,
of Hitler's Germany. And, and, uh, in
Weimar before Hitler came to power,
the magistrates who admitted them, and
most of them had been trained under, uh,
the second right. That is before World War
One. And maybe they flocked to, uh, uh,
the extreme right. Uh, very, uh, uh,
quickly public opinion in general did
not criticize measures taken against the
Jews,
uh,
at least until 1942 and as I said the
other day, they were, there were, um,
uh, so many, I did not see nations
of people that, that were, uh,
notes that said, uh, just to, to have
kind of come home with Ai, these reef,
you know, I'm sure that my neighbor,
he's a Jew and the cost of this were,
we're rather serious.
So what do we know about the reactions
of non Jewish French men and women to
what was going on?
Well,
late in 1940 900,000 people visited a,
an exposition that v she had put up
in the [inaudible]. Uh, in Paris, uh,
about the alleged links of Freemasons
that is free thinkers to Jews and to the
British. Uh, so I mean, if
you went into it, I mean,
this was just the equivalent a, well,
it wasn't art, the artistic equivalent,
but it was rather like the,
the, uh, if you went to that,
you were going in this with the same
sort of spirit is if you went to, uh,
one of the art shows to Hitler point
put on about a decade and art deco and
inner Jewish art and, and
this sort of stuff. Um,
another 114,000 people saw the exposition
when it on tour of the provinces.
Um,
another expedition called the
Jew in France attracted in 1942,
250,000 visitors in Paris
and 100,000 in the provinces.
Um, the German film, uh, that,
that the to which the Nazis, uh,
uh, in other writers and Germany's
had flocked called the juice Seuss,
which ends with, with a
Jew being hung, uh, to the,
to the frenzied applaud of
audiences, uh, was shown in France.
And people did go to see it.
Not huge numbers of people. Uh,
and there were even demonstrations in,
in two cities, but in tour, uh, you know,
on the wire,
uh,
people aligned up around the block
in order to come in and see this,
this essentially, um,
a Hitler, um, uh, uh,
uh, not, not see, uh, publicity, uh, uh,
a movie.
Uh,
and the collaboration is a
newspaper as you see Paul too,
or I am everywhere. Uh, sold a hundred,
so 250,000 copies in 1942
a and 300,000 by 1944.
Yes, 1944 a, which ends as
you know, in August in 1944.
Doesn't end in August, but, but,
uh, you know, the Germans are, are,
are Paris falls and at the end of August,
1944 and then gradually the
war moves, uh, to the east, um,
in, uh, uh, a novel, a by a
guy called a Lucia hobbit. J,
uh, called the lay a, they call him
would have sold 65 very right wing thing,
sold 65,000 copies, which
is a huge sale in France. I,
it's first month out.
And is published your claim that
only the shortage of paper, a war,
a war rationing of kept him from
selling another 200,000 copies.
And here's a glimpse of
what is in the novel.
I wished the victory of Germany cause
her war is my war. All my machine.
Oh my machine gun.
So often caressed in my dreams facing the
despised gangs of the Popular Front to
gilded ghettos of Sodom a hundred.
Well ane machinegun burse he exuded about
the site of Jews wearing yellow stars,
the Jewish backless,
the Jewish micro and all this now and all
in the French record is not very good.
Uh, even, uh, compared with other
countries, uh, they expect is spectacular.
The exception being Slovakia,
uh, which was, uh, uh,
certainly one of the worst places could
possibly have been, uh, as a Jew and,
and not too far from, from, uh,
uh, Os fits across the frontier in,
uh, in Poland. I was turned over both
natives and foreign zoos to Nazis, uh,
right away.
Uh,
Vichy France was the only country in
which local authorities deported Jews
without the presence of occupying forces.
And in Hungary, which had had
antisemitic legislation since 1920,
even the vicious admiral called
whore, the, he was not in this course,
but he was vicious. Anyway, HR, t,
h y m I handed over, no Jews, uh,
who are Hungarian Jews, uh, until, uh,
German occupation in 1944 a and then mark,
only 7% of the Jews disappeared.
I helped by Danes and
the proximity of Sweden.
The motto was just across the straights.
It's still just across the straits,
except there's a bridge now. Um, uh, yet
France was the country in which a great,
the greatest percentage of
Jews are, a great percentage
of Jews, uh, survived. Uh,
the war in all,
only 24% of the Jews were deported as
opposed to 78% in the Netherlands and 45%
from Belgium and ultimately
50% from, from, uh, Hungary.
Now there's another thing going on
too. I mean, just look at the map. Uh,
there's nowhere to hide in the Netherlands
or in Belgium of basically in Belgium
is flat. There's no, uh, and
I'll give you some examples of,
of where Jews say were saved
because of, uh, of, of,
of geographic, uh, uh, of geographic,
kind of doing a, I mean, the,
uh, uh, of the lay of the land,
but such figures that were marshaled by
those apologizing for the Vichy regime
regime and to repeat something that
they're borrowing from Robert Paxton.
And I said the other day, a Vichy
might have a save the French state.
I in quotes, uh, but it
lost, uh, the French. Uh,
there were French, the French nation. Now
what about resistance? Uh, first of all,
what about me to all
Francois? Me Too long. Um,
was the president of France
between 1981, may of 1981. And,
um, uh, she would have been out, uh,
when w 1981 and 91 was it,
it was [inaudible] 91.
The end of his term, I can't
remember. No, it was 14 years.
It should be 81 to [inaudible] 95
and now the term is five years.
Uh, Francois Mitterrand was, uh,
uh, what was a socialist, uh, who,
um, started out his term in 1981
with lots of, of, of socialist,
um, economic policies and sort
of backed up off from them,
but became somebody who was
extremely popular in France. Um,
and as he was dying at the, toward
the very end of his life, uh,
maybe a year before he died,
he had very serious illness.
The journalist knew it. And unlike the
journalist in the United States, you know,
where it's something like that
would be leaked immediately. Uh,
a journalist did not leak this fact,
but it was quite obvious that that falls
on me too. Mom was, was it was ill. Um,
and it, toward the end of his life to
facts about his life came up. It came out.
Um, the first is that he had
a very old daughter, uh, from,
uh, Aaliyah is all, if it had
nothing to do with his wife,
I'm necessarily common in a,
in the political France.
But the second and for our purposes
is much more important, uh,
was that he had himself been a
collaborator. This was the dark secret.
And He poured out his heart. Uh, he said
he had something he had to tell. Uh,
he wasn't telling himself that he had to
tell the French people and that he had
collaborated early in the war.
In fact,
somebody came up with a picture of him
in a right wing demonstration with the
quad differ or one of these
groups against immigrants, uh,
before World War Two. Now
he had second thoughts, uh,
fairly early into the war.
And he ends up, you know,
he heads an important branch of,
of the resistance organization. Uh,
but he came to grips with his own past,
uh,
as France was attempting to come
to grips at the very same time.
Now,
now to the resistance who resist maybe.
And why did they resist?
And again,
just as the question of collaboration,
uh,
was a party and the discovery
of massive collaboration.
And it wasn't just a few people, a few
elites. And this was the, you know,
the dark secret of the dark years
as Julian Jackson called, uh,
this period. Um, so, uh, is
the case with the resistance.
And as I began the lecture last
time I'm in Charleston, golf, uh,
was determined that the,
the France of the fourth republic was
to be built around his large body. Uh,
and a part of that was to
try to convince people, uh,
in France and abroad,
uh, that the godless,
we're the only resistors and that
they had heard the crackle of his,
uh, voice imposing voice across
the airwaves. And June 18th, uh,
19, uh, 40, uh, now, what can we say now?
First of all,
that the communists were arguably
the most important or most effective
resistors, uh, during,
uh, during the period. Uh,
and it's certainly that after the Jews
or the Communists suffered, uh, most,
uh, Vichy not only handed
the Nazis lists of those,
they arrested as communists,
but also executed a many of them
themselves beginning in 1941 for no other
reason. Then there, um, uh, uh,
political affiliation.
V She's minister of the Interior chose
Communist rather than those he called
good freshmen to be gunned down
by German firing squads, uh,
in the fortress of Bovela Vella.
Yeah. Outside of Paris. Now,
uh, the, the socialists presence.
And Socialist presence in the
resistance is an organized, forced,
was not as great. But there's some,
several obvious reasons for that.
The communists have benefited from the
fact that they had sales and virtually
every commune in France, and that's
what they call them, sell. Uh,
there are still in our
village of 300 people, uh,
a communist party cell,
which involves basically just five or
six of our friends, uh, who, or anything.
Then the about the communist of,
of Moscow in all of this. Um,
but who are defenders of, of, uh, of,
uh, uh, uh, those who have no one else,
uh, to defend them. And that
sort of thing, including are
different. The former, uh,
a school teacher and some of
our best friends in the world.
And occasionally in my mailbox I'll
find an invitation from the sell of Bala
Zuke, uh, to a communist party,
a gathering, uh, where, uh,
they, they, they've asked me to talk on
the, on the collapse of a, of capitalism.
You don't have to explain to them that
capitalism isn't probably going to
collapse in the near future. And then
we all, after some political discussion,
we all drink, uh, uh,
illegal wine. Essentially.
There's this wine called clamp clamp,
tall as in Clinton,
but it's nothing to do
with Clinton. Um, that,
that is was called those sort of the
vat food a little bit. Uh, and it grows,
it grows all over the place,
the grapes do, and, and, and
because it grows. So, uh,
so wildly, uh, uh, it became sort of
illegal to produce a particular grape.
And so one of the parts of being a
party of resistance is you don't pay any
attention to that. Uh, and to
that extent, I agree with that.
And so we would drink these
bouts of Trento and I, I've done,
I've drunk a bottles of Clariton
tone with, with, um, uh,
a guy who joined the
party who is still alive.
He and his wife joined the Communist
Party in 1934 a and he is still,
uh, he, he's a painter and he painted
lots of people, a lots of the painting.
He was done. I was in prison, uh, in Paris
and when he was very lucky to be, uh,
to escape a execution,
but in part because of the complicity of,
of a guard and we think that they joined
the communist party two years before
the, uh, before the, uh, the Spanish civil
war, uh, is just incredible. So the, the,
the point of this is that, uh, the, the
advantage of the company's Party had,
is that they already have organized,
they have people in most area,
every large village who
represent the communist party.
So it's easy to organize your comrades,
uh,
cause you know who they are and you
can trust them after all these years.
So they have some advantages there.
Another advantage of the communist party
had a, and as I alluded to this before,
is there, they were basically the party
of the Shemi know, uh, of the railroad,
the railroad workers and the
engineers in any station.
You go to go to a wall sometime where
I teach and I go to often who we have
friends there, um, and look in the,
in the railroad station. It's just,
it's just unbelievable.
There's this huge plaque with
about 200 names of Shemi, no,
a railroad workers, uh, in the largest
sense who, uh, uh, were killed,
executed by the Nazis,
uh, or by, uh, uh, by the,
the French fascist, uh, during the war
and even in every railroad station.
So the advantage there
is that as you know,
this from seeing all these movies
I'm sure about the resistance,
is pretty easy to blow up railroad tracks.
Uh,
and so what they were able
to do is blow up, you know,
how can you watch the whole whole train
line between a digital and Leon and my
say, for example, uh, there wasn't no Tj,
obviously that just started on the
28th of September, 1981. Uh, so, uh,
it's easy for a couple of Liga of the
guys to go out and, and to blow up, um,
uh,
block the track and it takes a long time
to fix the track and they blow up that
one and then, and they fixed
that one, then boom, further
on down the line. Uh, so,
uh, they were very active
in the north and you know,
and Lilo [inaudible] Bay to
acquire, uh, [inaudible] to,
uh, so, and, and, and they were
very much a part of the stage.
Jt that is the General
Confederation of Labor.
And they were more apt to be communists,
uh, uh, than other, any other, uh, party.
Uh, and this is true in the
suburbs of Paris, um, Eh, eh,
as well. So, um,
they also had great strength.
My metal, metallurgical, uh,
workers,
uh,
and thus metallurgical metallurgical
workers have access to,
to flammable explosive materials
and, and this sort of stuff. Uh,
and so, um, they also,
Dan organized very damaging industrial
strikes, particularly in 1944.
And these strikes help give people a sense
of hope that there's light at the end
of the tunnel. And of
course, the, you know,
the beat people listening to BBC and that
sort of thing. A story about BBC, uh,
two stories, uh, again, I hate to
keep referring to this village,
but I wrote a book on this village
called histones and Bazooka. And,
and at the end of it, uh, one of the two
last chapters about the schools, but a,
a school, but I had to cover it, you
know, do Vichy and I headed to Vichy very,
very delicately, very delicately. Uh,
it was obviously that in
our village that the priest,
that we don't have a
pretty steady more there,
but the priest was at Peyton
east and lots of people hated it.
I'm not just because of his politics, but
a lot of people liked his politics. Uh,
but he used to sort of shout at people
in the confessional and there's all sorts
of funny stories.
He insisted that women sit on one side
of the church still and that men, uh,
on the other, but, um,
I, this was a village.
This is a village that wasn't an area of
great resistance even though arms were
parachuted down to, um, uh, on
a plateau near where we live.
This is done here in, in,
uh, in the [inaudible],
but there were two people in a,
in the resistance and one of, uh,
is still alive and very old ma'am.
Uh, and they would hide things.
This is the pay calcare. I
mean, it's a limestone country
in big, big goat, uh, uh,
you know, caves along the river and
you can hide things easily there.
And I wanted to talk to this man
about the, about the resistance and I,
uh, he's the uncle of a
friend and I invited finite,
invited he and his wife
over and I made clear,
I wanted to ask him some questions,
not let as a journalist, but,
but I'd been there in this place for 20
years and I knew the guy a little bit.
And, uh, above all I knew was
his, his family. And he said yes,
he would come and he would talk to me
about it because I'd been there so long.
Um, but then he never showed up. He
didn't want to talk about it. Uh,
he couldn't talk about it. Uh,
because of, of, uh, you know,
it's really like people coming
back from world war one a,
the people that talked and boasted were
the ones who would dress up in military
uniforms.
When's towns had been liberated.
It's if they had been there in the
beginning, out in the bushes, the Mckee,
the resistors. But he was a real
one. We didn't want to talk about it,
but I also knew speaking in BBC, and
this is the transition that I had heard,
the story that a man in
Bala Zuke had, um, had a,
in this particular village
had alerted the authorities,
the Vichy authorities, the fact that
that some people were listening to BBC,
now you could be executed for listening
to BBC. That was a capital crime.
Uh, and I mean, often they wouldn't,
if you were somebody they knew,
they wouldn't do that or whatever.
But you know, you denounce, uh,
you denounce somebody for listening
to the BBC. And that's not,
it's not as bad as denouncing
somebody's saying he's a Jew, but,
but it ain't good. Uh, so I
ask his friend of mine, um,
an older man who could remember the
war and I said, what about that? Uh,
and I wait until the appropriate
circumstances to ask him. He said, no, no,
it's just, uh, I don't, I don't pay
any attention to it. It's just rumor.
It's just rumors, a vicious rumor
that he's on the, you know, rumor,
they believe rumors and all that.
But
so in franchise JBS up on Tay,
I kinda snuck around a little bit,
serpent head around and I
asked some, uh, you know,
trusted people who are very discreet.
What about it?
And it turned out it was his father.
It was his father who did it and who
was associated with the priest in the
village. And I knew this man, he died
long time ago, 10 or 15 years ago.
But I knew the man and such
secrets are they best buried? Uh,
I buried it in the French edition
of my book. It's not an ad,
it's not an in the Dutch addition
either. Uh, it's in the English edition,
but hidden, hidden away. Uh,
cause he'll never know it.
Never see and couldn't read the English
edition. So all this stuff, you know,
it's kind of delicate, uh, that
whole business about, um, anyway, so,
uh, uh, people, the,
the comedies party became the
party of the 75,000 martyrs.
A because probably that many
communists, uh, uh, died. Whereas this,
the socialist had a lack of, uh,
you know, a lack of, of, of, um, uh,
Oregon structural organization and many
of their leaders like Leon Blum. Uh,
we're in, uh, uh, in a jail, uh, and as a,
and as I said last time
just passing there,
it also was it I left
when Catholic resistance,
Social Catholics and no
resistance publication condemned
racism and antisemitism
with the vigor vigor of the newspaper.
Tim went, our team went asha,
Katya or Christian witness basically.
Um,
so,
and what about Jews?
It's hard to resist if you're being
tracked down and being arrested. Uh,
it's, um, and by the way,
remember Pierre Leval, uh,
who was the prime minister through
much of the period. He was the,
on another occasion when, um, uh, the
Germans insisted that that French parents,
uh,
that,
that French adults who are Jews be
transported from a certain sector, uh,
but they didn't ask for the children.
Pure level said,
send the children to
for me to vi Pi three.
I mean that in a very ironic
sense, you know, family work, uh,
country family values,
put the children together.
And so the children bounced off in the,
in the, in the railroad car. But in fact,
I know this Australian guy who
was a, a young, very young man.
I in Paris, who's Jewish
guy called Jack Adler. Uh,
and I met him in Melbourne a few years
ago, and he, um, uh, survived the war,
but he was 16. He was in an underground
Jewish resistance group in Paris,
and he wrote a book about it. Then he
went off and made a lot of money, uh, in,
in Melbourne. And he got out, he
survived. I became a, you know, a bear,
a cake producer.
And then he went back in and got his phd
in French history at the University of
Melbourne with my friend Peter McPhee.
And He, um, uh, then he wrote this book,
very good book on the Jewish
resistance. But, you know,
Jewish resistance was organized in,
in, in, in Paris where there were,
there were lots of Jews and had every
conceivable reason to resist, uh,
but only in cities like Volvo where
they were all getting locked up, uh, uh,
very quickly and in Leone and other
places. Uh, so, uh, but, but this,
the reason I that I insist on this fact
that there wasn't an organized Jewish
resistance is because among the sort of
antisemitic residuals and the postwar
period is, is that the accusation
that Jews didn't resist,
they just kind of went off
to be slaughtered and all
of that and didn't put up a
fight, which of course this
is obviously not true. Now,
the role of Protestants has been often
privileged in the discussion of the
resistance. Um, again, to
repeat what I said, uh,
lots of the most part,
most the greatest percentage
of Protestants are down
here again in the owl dash
and in the gap down here and this event
mountains basically also up in the
Jerome on the other side of the,
uh,
in the valleys that go down to the Rhone
River into the drum, t, r. O, m, e. Um,
and the most famous case of,
of Jewish children being saved
is that of a Protestant village,
which I'm going to write it on the
board because it deserves it, uh,
called the Lewis Chambong sooner Lino,
right on the edge of the owl dash in,
uh, near, near the [inaudible]. But, but,
but in the mountains and what they did
in this little teeny village as they
organize this kind of a false
id identification network,
and they took Jewish kids from Santa
tn and Leonel in other places in that
region. I mean, that, that region is
an area that always sent, you know,
lots of immigrants to, uh, it's very
Catholic region. But in this case,
in that village, Very Protestant, uh,
had sent lots of immigrants to
Leon and to a Sante Tien. And so,
um, they have, they adopted
all sorts of Jewish kids.
And then when the, when the Germans
would come through, uh, you know,
you could hear them coming,
they would hide the kids or they'd
go off into the woods and, and,
but there seem to be an awful lot of
kids in the Germans would go through,
my God,
these people must be very Catholic.
They're having babies all over the place.
Look at all these kids.
And they never figured it out. And in fact
that they were, they were, um, they were,
uh, uh, they were Protestant and, uh,
lots of, uh, of people were saved.
And there's a document you're on
this, um, guy called Rod QED, word HR.
Edward,
um,
D has on two really interesting books
on probably the best books on the
resistance that are in English.
And he made,
he noted something very interesting about,
uh, a commune, a village in, in the,
a couple of villages in the
Savanna mountains, uh, in
which Protestants resisted.
And he noticed that, you know,
in, in that part of France,
the religious wars had been the 16th,
17th,
and 18th century had been very bloody
and they'd pitted basically the armies of
the king of the, of the most
Catholic king against a, um,
even though that's the title
that they call it a Spanish
name. But anyway, uh, of,
of Louis the 14th and all these people
against a Protestants and he noticed that
one,
particularly a resistant village,
that's a huge mission cross overlooking
the village that had been planted there,
uh, in the 16th century as a, as a
sign of, of, or in the 17th century,
I don't know which war it was as a sign
of victory of conquest by the state and
the Catholic Church over
these Protestants does.
Looking at something like that
all the time, make you more,
want to resist a regime is closely
tied to right wing Catholicism.
Well, who knows? But Protestants were
overrepresented in the resistance.
But as I said, Catholics
resistance, resistant to, and
then the, you know, the, uh,
from the point of view of the resistance,
or I suppose anybody looking at this,
uh, it's easy to, uh, uh,
denounced, uh, many, uh, uh,
Catholic archbishops and
bishops who didn't give one
damn about the Jews and who
embraced Vichy with,
with a great passion.
But yet in many places of Catholic,
uh, villages that had Catholics,
uh, resisting, and most people in
France are nominally Catholics.
The role of priests Wa
wa was considerable, uh,
that Po and the role of teachers were
of an ste to have a primary school
teachers, uh, was, uh,
important as well. Now, priests,
I don't know what you priests
and, and, and, uh, um,
and the school teachers that are kind
of opinion makers or whatever the phrase
is, I mean, they are, you know,
they are people that, along
with the mayor that, that,
that,
that sort out problems in a village.
And so if you have a priest who
FISM enough of this stuff, you know,
he can throw his weight. Uh,
and to do good things. Uh,
and, uh, well, again, look at the
payoff was wrong. Uh, father, uh,
a Xiong tonight. Um, so,
um, uh, again, the, the,
the situation of, of, um, of, uh,
of the Catholic churches is extremely,
um, uh, is extremely, uh, complicated.
Um, and the real explosion of, of,
of work on the resistance
has been dominated by the
stories of ordinary people
taking very unordinary choices,
big time choices.
A friend of mine called John Suites who
taught at University of Kansas. It K u,
um, he did a book on
Claremore fit hall, um,
because that's where the sorrow and the
pity he had the town that it had been
focused on. And his book is
called choices in Vichy, France.
Uh, and he was not critical of the packs
and the, which is the Canon after all. Uh,
but he argued that you
have to give him a wider,
a description of a ride or definition
of resistance in trying to determine how
many people resisted packs and thinks
that about 2% of the French population
resisted. John thinks sweets
things, and it's a very good book.
Choices in Vichy France thinks
that, uh, uh, uh, oh, maybe about,
you know, I can't remember what he says.
18 or 20% of the population resistance.
Well, what does resistance,
uh, it's, I mean, lots of
people took big time chances.
Smuggling weapons, you're going to get
killed if they catch you, you're gone,
toast, finished. Uh, but
you know, if you know,
you're in a movie theater and they're
doing the showing the documentary, I mean,
before the, the film, uh, there's always
this two minute news Saturday session,
which I can remember as a tiny little boy,
you know,
with always the same kind of
voices, uh, uh, giving the news.
And this would be the German,
the German news translated into French.
And if you whistle and you boo
whistling is mooing, uh, uh, in France,
or if you refuse to step off the
sidewalk to let a German officer pass,
I mean that it's self as a, uh,
a passive resistance. And so, uh,
certainly more people resisted according
to this definition. Uh, then, uh,
uh, and this was a type of, of choice,
uh, in, uh, in, in Vichy, France.
Um, one of the ways that people resisted
with, for example, passing, uh, these, uh,
printed these newspapers that
sort of mimeographed. Uh,
and there was a whole clandestine press
and it was very important because it
would tell people in Normandy that there
had been strikes and Sante Tien, uh,
or strikes and Maasais or would give
news on where people thought that the,
you know, the battles were
going in, that kind of thing.
How do you get newspapers around? Well,
you just take a bunch of them on a bus,
a bus and Leo for example,
and the bus is going along
plastic rom plus Bella Coola,
and you just hold your hand out the
window and drop all the leaflets,
or they'd be leaflets against when the
Berlin Philharmonic Orchestra played in
the Lille, uh, somebody did
that. They took all these, uh,
these little handwritten and mimeographed,
uh, uh, uh, pieces of paper that said,
no, you know, don't ask, don't go assist.
Don't go listen to the Berlin
Philharmonic. Let us resist.
And that's a form of resistance, to not
going to hear the Berlin Philharmonic
and drop them just like that.
And, and, and, uh, the old ones,
a very effective center of the resistance
I told you about mark block and there
because in the owner,
these things called en Francais Tabula,
which are basically not tunnels,
but there are passages that that began
in the 16th century to protect silk from
being a raw silk from being rained
on in a pretty rainy climate.
And so the Tub Moodle also grew up the
quote who's, which is this, this, uh, uh,
old working class neighborhood that
was outside of only a next to Leon, uh,
in 1852 and these trouble,
you can duck into these trouble.
And that's why the resistance was so
important in, in Leon Paul. And that's,
that's where mark block went when Mark
Block was, had, had gone down to here.
He was up in, uh, near gay here and
he just kind of anxious and he says,
I should go do something. So he goes to
Leon and he participates in, you know,
in the resistance. And of course,
he pays for it with his life. Um,
what about women? Now? For decades,
nobody paid attention to the role
of women in the resistance. Now,
women were, were very rare
in the heels. By the way,
the term McKee means, uh,
basically organized resistors.
A mucky in French or Leymah
key are, is kind of a, a brush,
a that's very sick brush behind,
which you could hide in Corsica.
That's where it comes from originally.
And then in the south of France on what
you call in French, the [inaudible], the,
you know, really dry
rocky, uh, uh, countryside.
And so by 1943,
by the end of 1943,
in many parts of France,
the Mckee rule by night that they have
increased in their forces are swollen by
people moving into the resistance.
Now, some people, you know,
had to feed these folks.
Some people had the darn
their socks or give, you know,
nip them things just to
stay, uh, stay warm some way.
People had to pass messages and they're
all sorts of stories about women on
bicycles. Uh, it's, it's one of these
sort of things that you see in movies,
but if women on bicycle sort of charming,
a young woman, charming the guards, uh,
you know,
if they,
if they have the bad luck to fall upon
the militia or a German guards and having
a written message,
which is a terrible idea,
but at least to have a verbal
communication of passing
messages into the hills.
Now the largest resistance movement in
most effective in Europe by far the Noah,
uh, is in you, in ex Yugoslavia. And,
and that's because of
the terrain in Bosnia,
Herzegovina and cross he Croatia and in
Serbia and they have entire divisions
with hospitals and mobile hospitals
and all of that with the British,
a parachuting things in.
But if you look at this map,
it's not surprising to see why there's
very little resistance here. Can,
where are you going to hide there?
There's nowhere to hide.
So the Mckee and the resistance, I mean
there are Maki all over the place, but,
but it was easier in the south and it's
by the end of 43 that I said last time
about the find a k on your door in the
morning with someone was there to put k
on the door in the morning. And
uh, uh, and, and there you go.
Uh,
and so the role of women has been much
more important that then than people had
thought. And there are
all sorts of, uh, uh,
why a big literature are
growing literature on this now.
And also in some places and
[inaudible] for example,
the numbers of Mucky [inaudible] of people
in the Ma, the resistance of my key,
uh,
were swollen.
It was swollen by refugees from
Spain or even from Poland. Uh,
so you have a, you know, you have
these people living out there. Uh, and,
uh,
the,
the only three times in France during
the period do they try to take on German
military units in a pitched battle?
Bad idea,
terrible idea. One is right near
Claremont fell, uh, here. Uh,
one is in the vacuum, uh, near Gunna
Oberth down here. And the third,
I don't remember where it
is. Um, so that, that's,
that's w w w that doesn't work very well
because they don't have the kind of big
time tanks and, and that,
that kind of thing. But they
were able to regroup. I mean,
are places near us. There's a
village way up in the hill. It's God,
it's so beautiful. Uh, church fabolous
church, a place called teen with his,
uh, with his Roman, uh,
poor of Forte, a Parte,
a entryway. That's just
fabulous. And there,
there was a whole bunch of these people
up there and they had some fairly
considerable arms. This is the pitch
battle, but then they get denounced.
There are always people that are going
to sell other people's lives away.
There's no question about it.
They were true believers, uh,
in the regime that's
going to sell people away.
And the next thing they know and another
case near us to next thing they know,
Bam,
here come the parachute to serve coming
in there and the tanks are rolling up or
the,
you know,
the smaller vehicles with machine gun
room at big machine guns in this kind of
stuff. And they are gone.
They are just massacred.
And there all sorts of places around
where we live. We're where people were,
were shot. And if you help, if you are a
woman or you or anyone, you're a priest,
you're a, uh, you're anyone,
you're a school teacher and you help
people and the, and they, you know,
and they catch you. And particularly
if you've killed the German, you know,
you're gone. That's it. I
told her the story of that
bud, the woman the other day,
it was a collaborator up on, uh, you know,
along the Rhone River and they blew
her brains out. And, and, and uh,
the resisters did, and in pennants
as it were in punishment, they,
uh, just, you know, the execute people
just take hostages and execute them.
Begin with people you think are
communists and they just shoot, shoot,
shoot the other people.
Look what happened in,
in next check in Czech Republic
and next Czechoslovakia in Prague.
I've gone to the place where Richard
Heidrick was one of the very worst of the
worst. I was assassinated
by these, uh, by, um, uh,
by check McKee. And he's gone down as he's
coming in and he fights them, you know,
when he finally, mortally wounded
and all that. And, and they go,
they go and they hide in this church that
I went to visit and Prague a couple of
years ago. And, you know, they
of course parish horribly,
but they took an entire village
called ladies and kill everybody.
It's rather like Sarah
farmers book orders are gone,
which really needs no
needs. No, uh, um, Eh,
you know, it needs to know,
uh, a discussion now. Now,
what, what led people?
Well, first of all, one, one quick
point is that again, I, I've said that,
that if you took a map of, of, of, I've
said this I guess maybe more recently,
but it's of, of decriminalization, uh,
allegiance to the French
revolution in 1,790,
the elections of 1949 in 19, uh, 81, uh,
you would have virtually the same
[inaudible] are left and the virtually the
same day pop them all are right. That
doesn't work for the resistance. Brittany,
which has always been
extremely conservative, uh,
was a big resistance area.
The same goes with rural Normandy.
And of course that's the most well known
because of the invasion. You know, the,
the, the Americans and the British and
the Australians and New Zealanders and
Canadians, uh, invade here.
Uh, the Germans thought they
were going to invade here,
but they invade here. Um,
and they'd already, uh,
the resistance that already taken out
lots of rail lines and things like that.
In general,
Eisenhower said that they were worth
two divisions or something like that.
A rural normity is
always been conservative,
so that that interpretation
doesn't really work. Uh,
there was lots of resistance in
ovarian, which is conservative. Uh,
and there was tons of resistance
in the limo. Zheng Tao, uh,
thus explaining that one reason that
explaining the massacre and the 10th of
June, 1944, or I'll do a
sort of done. So, uh, uh,
the g you can't,
there's no kind of geographic determinism,
a regional determinism.
There is some geographic determinism
that is the lay of the land,
but there's no regional,
there's not a predisposed disposition
or Brett told not to resist because they
do resist the resistant. Not
everybody, but the resistance is,
is important in Brittany and
the sort of kinds of places.
Now without question,
the big defining moment swelling,
the ranks of the resistance
is this visa do 12,
I only got 12 in February.
The s t o w at that is the service of
obligatory work where the Germans say,
we want men from each region to go
to Germany and work in the factories.
The reason is they have so
many people, dad, so many
killed, uh, and they need work.
And this swells, um, uh,
the ranks of resistors.
This forces families and individuals
to make choices in Vichy,
France. Again, to borrow
from John's a title, um,
and this builds on an,
uh,
a policy and a June 42
announced by pure Laval that,
uh, called the [inaudible] or the relief
team that would send specialized French
workers to, uh, Germany in
exchange for the release of,
of French prisoners of
war from 1940. Haha. Uh,
but now they say, well, you got you,
you got to go. And they'll show up,
uh, into your village Inn and you
better be ready to go. 650,000,
uh, workers were sent to Germany
as consecrate script labor.
This also contributes to discredit
further the Vichy regime,
visa vi. Uh, it's, um, uh, you know,
its population,
uh,
and the grumbling about
Petain the grumbling about
shortages and the grumbling
about the German soldiers. A
give way now to more, uh, open,
uh, a resentment. Uh, the bishop of,
of lead, a guy called the colony.
Now Leah na,
who had kept quiet about the increasingly
obvious faith of Jews announced it was
no longer a duty for a Christian to go
to work in Germany and Jase Jase ms here.
Um, and so this swells, uh,
this nomadic tribe of resistors,
uh,
living from day to day in
the mountains and the hills.
And, you know, it's, is it
a scary existence? I mean,
you're listening through the night,
uh,
or in the day for the sudden
the roar of the machines,
the roar of the rival of airplanes
or a fast speeding German cars,
uh, uh, and you're
freezing in snow, a bored,
tired, anxious, uh, far, far away,
a demoralized and understandably
a terrifying. Now,
most of the, my key, we're
city folks, they were, uh,
that the majority and most of France
is not, you know, are not urban people.
Uh, in 1943, uh, in 19, uh, uh,
44, uh, you know,
that was because it was easier to round
up people to be sent in the s s t o that
is the obligatory labor service.
Uh,
if you were from a city where you had
all sorts of soldiers who come out and,
and, uh, uh, pick you up. Um, and so,
I mean,
the lien was,
that probably is the classic example
that is in the area in which a orders for
Glenn, uh, takes, uh, of where it
became a, uh, uh, it was not a,
you know, not a mass mass movement,
but were you still have, uh, uh,
all sorts of people that are part
of underground Oregon underground
organizations or you know,
are part of the Gaullist resistance.
And Joel Moolah reason,
I have his name up here,
he was a former prefect
of the [inaudible],
which is the department of shots with,
you know, in the boats, uh, south Paris,
beautiful cathedral town.
And then he ends up himself getting
denounced in tortured, uh, and,
and all of that.
But the resistance,
whether they were gall us or whether they
were communists or whether they had no
affiliation at all, a party affiliation,
um, the resistance depended on,
on neighborhoods, small town
and above wall village networks.
Thus, uh, the role of
the school teacher, uh,
or some kind of local,
a leader, a communist,
was wounded by French,
French gendarme in a village.
And the vibe that is the department of
tunnel and central pay and all of that on,
on the Mediterranean, he
was hidden by a peasant, uh,
in this one of these networks.
But his untreated wound
developed gangrene to doctors,
took care of him,
alerted by the wife of an agent of a
resistance organization in all 10 people
combined at the risk of their life,
uh, of saving the life of one,
um, a resistor. And of course,
ironically in areas like the Limu Museum,
that if I, I insisted and I'm right
in doing so, uh, that, uh, you know,
as Paxton and others have argued that
that Vichy saw itself as the regime of
Lactam of the land.
That the real values were Joan of arc
and peasants and all that business,
the cult of the peasant resistor in
areas like the Limu Zahn that is around,
uh, the motion and, and the, to
the, you know, the massacre at two.
Then all these places, uh,
was an important one. Uh, as,
as well.
Um,
now after the June six
landings in Normandy, uh,
and, uh, you know, the troops are
also moving up, uh, after the,
the landings in the south or moving
up, uh, their own valley, you know,
killing lots of people on their
way. Uh, then, um, you know,
it became easier to resist.
And so therefore the temptation
after the war was to say, Oh,
you know what a seizure it, they lie.
You know, I was resisting and it wasn't,
I wasn't idea, Oh yes, your gun was
always ready, et Cetera, et cetera.
And everybody kind of jumped forward and
provide the, in the prefecture, uh, uh,
of the l dash there's, you
know, they have this big,
sort of a joyous celebration
when the town is,
is liberated,
and then they noticed some
of the resisters notice
they're all sorts of people
dressed up in fancy military
clothes and all of that,
and had nothing to do
the resistance at all.
Some of them were trying to save their,
their skins, uh, because, uh, you know,
they had rather different sympathies
a few weeks ago before that,
where a few months before that,
as I said,
near our village or as a priest who
was laying up in the wall and shot down
because he had killed because
he had had day, ah, ah,
to lunch and was a fascist at sometime.
Earlier in,
in the period, uh, there
was about 24,000, um, uh,
McKee who were killed in the
liberation of France and in, in, in,
in Paris above all.
But in other cities as well,
you can walk along and you see
signs that say, you know, uh, ECA,
Tone Bay here fell on the
24th of August, 1944. So,
and so, uh, from one of
the resistance groups.
And occasionally you'll see a flower,
a new flowers put there by somebody
who remembers or somebody aware of the
collective memory or especially around
the prefecture of police in Paris.
I've always thought it was cruel.
This is a cynical,
but they should have put in some
of the fancier quarters of Paris.
And posse and places like that. Uh,
you know, you see a Collabo, hey,
uh, you know, Miss [inaudible],
uh, a madame, uh, you know, look,
goes into Kelechi shows, uh, uh, 1940,
1944, but that's not nice
and not very generous. Uh,
and,
and I make no apologies for it.
Um, there were, I mean, again,
just to end with these little,
I'll just end with this,
that at, at the time of the pup
home trial when pop home was,
was arguing, he says, well, I was a good
bureaucrat. My superiors liked what I did,
and I was protecting these other Jews
by sending away the hundreds, whom,
you know, I made possible their
departure from the Gao. Standish Hall.
There was another little story came along
and I didn't remember where I read it,
but there was a young woman who
worked in the SEC as a secretary,
I in the prefecture or,
or in the police or somewhere like that.
And she, um, because
of people like popcorn,
you had lists of all the people who
are Jews are all the people who were
communists in these, you'd
homed are in bold Dole, uh,
and, um, that these
things are kept in files.
But this is before the computer, the
quiet violence of the computer. Uh,
and these were lists
that were done by hand,
and she simply went in to
the drawers and rip them up,
ripped up the list, and
put the, the scrap paper,
not in the wastepaper basket,
but in her pocket,
and went out and deposited in the first
poo bell or garbage can that she found
heroic act choices and Vichy France.
It made you think,
it made you decide what to do.